MY GUEST FOR THIS HOUR TODAY IS
UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT, VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, WELCOME TO
THE SHOW.
>> Reporter: GREETINGS.
GREETINGS TO YOU ALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS CALLED
VLADIMIR PUTIN A WAR CRIMINAL,
AND YET YOU HAVE CALLED FOR
NEGOTIATIONS WITH HIM.
WILL IT BE HARD, WILL IT BE
PAINFUL FOR YOU TO HAVE TO SIT
DOWN WITH PUTIN, WERE HE COULD
AGREE AND APPRECIATE WITH HIM?
>> Translator: I AM READY FOR
NEGOTIATIONS WITH HIM.
I WAS READY OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND I THINK THAT -- I
THINK THAT WITHOUT NEGOTIATIONS
WE CANNOT END THIS WAR.
I THINK THAT ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
THINK THAT THIS DIALOGUE IS
SHALLOW AND THAT IT IS NOT GOING
TO RESULT IN ANYTHING, THEY JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
VERY VALUABLE.
IF THERE IS JUST 1% CHANCE FOR
US TO STOP THIS WAR, I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE THIS
CHANCE.
WE NEED TO DO THAT.
I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT THE RESULT
OF THIS NEGOTIATIONS.
IN ANY CASE, WE ARE LOSING
PEOPLE ON A DAILY BASIS,
INNOCENT PEOPLE ON THE GROUND.
RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE COME TO
EXTERMINATE US, TO KILL US, AND
WE HAVE DEMONSTRATED THE DIGNITY
OF OUR PEOPLE AND OUR ARMY, THAT
WE ARE -- WE ARE ABLE TO DEAL A
POWERFUL BLOW, WE ARE ABLE TO
STRIKE BACK, BUT UNFORTUNATELY
OUR DIGNITY IS NOT GOING TO
PRESERVE THE LIVES, SO I THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO USE ANY FORMAT,
ANY CHANCE IN ORDER TO HAVE THE
POSSIBILITY OF NEGOTIATING THE
POSSIBILITY OF TALKING TO PUTIN,
BUT IF THESE ATTEMPTS FAIL, THAT
WOULD MEAN THAT THIS IS A THIRD
WORLD WAR.
>> YOU KNOW THE RUSSIAN DEMANDS,
THEY WANT YOU TO RECOGNIZE THAT
CRIMEA IS PART OF RUSSIA, THAT
THE TWO REPUBLICS IN THE DONBAS
ARE INDEPENDENT REPUBLICS.
THEY WANT A GUARANTEE, PERHAPS
IN THE UKRAINIAN CONSTITUTION,
THAT UKRAINE WILL NEVER BE A
MEMBER OF NATO.
ARE YOU WILLING TO MAKE THOSE
COMPROMISES?
>> Translator: THERE ARE
COMPROMISES FOR WHICH WE CANNOT
BE READY AS AN INDEPENDENT
STATE.
ANY COMPROMISES RELATED TO OUR
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY AND OUR
SOVEREIGNTY AND THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT IT,
THEY HAVE NOT GREETED RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS WITH A BUNCH OF
FLOWERS, THEY HAVE GREETED THEM
WITH BRAVERY, THEY HAVE GREETED
THEM WITH WEAPONS IN THEIR
HANDS.
SO FORCIBLY YOU CANNOT MAKE
YOURSELF A FRIEND, YOU CANNOT
CURRY FAVOR WITH THE CITIZENS OF
ANOTHER COUNTRY FORCIBLY.
YOU CANNOT JUST MAKE A PRESIDENT
OF ANOTHER COUNTRY TO RECOGNIZE
ANYTHING BY THE USE OF FORCE.
SO EVERYTHING THAT THEY ARE
DOING IS NOT JUST ABOUT
POLITICS, IT'S ABOUT -- IT'S
ABOUT REALITY.
THEY HAVE MADE THEIR WAY TO KERR
SAN REGION BUT PEOPLE ARE
FEELING HATRED AND ANIMOSITY AND
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO KILL
RUSSIANS BECAUSE RUSSIANS HAVE
KILLED THEIR CHILDREN.
YOU CANNOT REVERSE THIS
SITUATION ANYMORE.
YOU CANNOT JUST DEMAND FROM
UKRAINE TO RECOGNIZE SOME
TERRITORIES AS INDEPENDENT
REPUBLICS.
THESE COMPROMISES ARE SIMPLY
WRONG.
I CANNOT RECOGNIZE PERSONALLY AS
A PRESIDENT AND SECONDLY AS A
CITIZEN AND THIRDLY YOU CANNOT
FORCE PEOPLE TO LOVE THE ENEMY.
THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
WHAT YOU CAN DO IS TO MAKE A
PAUSE AND JUST DECIDE ON HOW WE
ARE GOING TO LIVE FURTHER ON.
WHAT HAS TO BE DONE IN ORDER TO
PUT AN END TO THE WAR, TO
PREVENT FURTHER WARS, AND HOW TO
FIND AND APPROACH THESE
TERRITORIES WHICH ARE
TEMPORARILY OCCUPIED.
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT MATTER
BECAUSE PART OF THESE
TERRITORIES WERE OCCUPIED EIGHT
YEARS AGO AND DURING ENTIRE
PERIOD OF EIGHT YEARS THEY HAVE
BEEN BRAIN WASHING PEOPLE AND
CHILDREN ON WHO THEY ARE.
THEY'VE BEEN TELLING THEM THAT
THEY HAVE PRESERVED THEIR LIVES,
THEY HAVE BEEN TELLING LIES THAT
UKRAINIANS ARE FASCISTS, THEY
HAVE BEEN FILLING THEIR HEADS
WITH LIES FOR MANY YEARS AND
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF
THAT TO FIND UNDERSTANDING.
YOU DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND WHAT
INFORMATION POLICIES MEAN,
THEREFORE, WE HAVE TO COME UP
WITH A MODEL WHERE UKRAINE WILL
NOT LOSE IT'S TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY.
WE CANNOT CONCEDE TO IT.
BUT STILL WE HAVE TO FIND A
MODEL OF UNDERSTANDING TO
PREVENT FURTHER WARS BETWEEN OUR
TERRITORIES THAT WE CONTROL AND
TEMPORARY OCCUPIED TERRITORIES.
SO WHATEVER THE DISCUSSIONS THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR NEGOTIATING
ALLEGATIONS, I THINK THAT IT'S
JUST -- THE TWO OF US, ME AND
PUTIN, WHO CAN MAKE AN AGREEMENT
ON THIS.
THE SECOND STORY IS RELATED TO
ULTIMATUMS THAT CANNOT BE THERE
EMANATING FROM ONE COUNTRY TO
ANOTHER COUNTRY.
I MEAN, IN GENERAL AND
CONCRETELY IN TERMS OF RUSSIA'S
ULTIMATUMS TO UKRAINE AND THERE
CAN BE NOT BE ANY ULTIMATUMS
FROM ANY COUNTRY WHATSOEVER TO
ANOTHER COUNTRY, REGARDLESS OF
THE ARMY THAT IT HAS, REGARDLESS
OF THE FINANCE, REGARDLESS OF
THE SIZE OF THE ECONOMY BECAUSE
IT'S INTERNATIONAL LAW.
IT'S SO RESPECT THE SOVEREIGNTY
OF EACH COUNTRY, THEREFORE
DIALECT IS THE ONLY WAY OUT.
IT IS THROUGH DIALECT THAT WE
HAVE TO SECURE THE MATTER OF
SECURITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
UKRAINE.
WE DO NOT WANT TO GIVE ANY
COUNTRY A POSSIBILITY TO ATTACK
US.
TODAY IT'S THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION, HOPEFULLY ANY OTHER
COUNTRY WILL NOT BE WILLING TO
ATTACK UKRAINE'S INDEPENDENCE,
BUT STILL YOU CAN SEE THAT
BELARUS LAUNCHED ROCKETS AGAINST
UKRAINE AT THE VERY BEGINNING,
THEREFORE, THAT'S A MATTER ON
THE TABLE RIGHT NOW, THEREFORE,
NATO COULD BE A SOURCE OF
GUARANTEES FOR UKRAINE, BUT WE
ARE NOT ACCEPTED AS A MEMBER OF
NATO, SO UKRAINE HAS TO SEEK FOR
OTHER SECURITY GUARANTEES FROM
INDIVIDUAL COUNTRIES, THAT WOULD
BE NYCHA MEMBERS, THAT IS WHAT
WE ARE PROPOSING, A NUMBER OF
LEADERS OF WORLD COUNTRIES COULD
BE THE SOURCE OF GUARANTEES FOR
UKRAINE,